Because it's being created within an activity, it can be
terminated as simply as rotating the phone into a different
orientation. So, should only ever be used for tasks whose
lifecycle is tied to the host activity, and is expected
to run for only a second or two. On mobile,
it's unwise to assume that even the most trivial network
access is going to happen quickly. So a better approach
would be to use a service. An application component without
the UI that's less likely to be
interrupted. Possibly scheduled using an inexact repeating alarm.
Even better, Android has a specialized solution know
as Async Adapter. And it's designed especially to schedule
your background data syncs as efficiently as possible. Better
still would be using Google Cloud Messaging. This let's
you notify your Async Adapter of changes on the
server side. So you're only ever initiating network requests
from your app when you know there's something to
be updated on the server. For now we're concentrating
on making our app work when it's in the foreground. But we'll return to
look at these approaches to invisibly updating
your app from the background a little
later. For now, keep in mind that the Refresh button and the new thread
solution is just a place holder while we hook up the rest of the app.